all right uh so philip asks much of
sports science studies are conducted on
young males are there any studies uh or
areas in particular that we would have
reason to think female physiology would
give different results um
you know that's a good question um
and i'm not totally
in terms of in terms of the physiology
thing i mean i think the the biggest
thing to consider
um
is that
certain
certain supplements in just certain
chemical compounds
sex hormones and in particular estrogen
can affect
how they're metabolized and the rate at
which they're metabolized and i know
we've talked about this on the podcast
before
but but kind of the poster child for
that is uh caffeine so
the rate at which uh women metabolize
caffeine uh varies based on where
they're at in their menstrual cycle and
might vary between
uh women using versus not using hormonal
contraception so
um
on a physiological level i mean anything
that might be interacting with sex
hormones or where sex hormones might
interact with the rate at which certain
compounds are metabolized uh
i think those would be the the places to
look if you're asking about this purely
from a physi physiology uh basis
personally though uh i'm going to answer
this question just you know what what
areas are there quite is there quite a
bit of research on males where i'd like
to see more research on females
um
and the first thing that comes to mind
which
uh generally wouldn't be the first thing
that would come to mind for me because i
generally don't care about them
is supplements a lot of supplement
research
there's a lot of studies on males not
that many on females
caffeine used to be one actually where
uh like 98 of the research was was on
male subjects uh and i think we talked
about this maybe two episodes ago but
within the last two years there's
there's been a uh
a renaissance oh i can't call it a
renaissance that's a rebirth there's
been an initial sons
of uh
exercise caffeine research in women so
that that's good to see but yeah a lot
of supplements uh bodies of research
lean very heavily towards male subjects
so i'd like to see
more female supplement studies um one
area where i'm particularly interested
uh
in
like
muscle type outcomes in women
is blood flow restriction research a lot
of that stuff leans pretty heavily
towards the male side of things and
there have been some initial studies
suggesting that maybe blood flow
restriction is uh
it has a
it might have a slightly smaller
anabolic effect in
females muscles than males muscles um
but again we we need to see some more
research before i could say that pretty
confidently but that's that's an area
where i'd like to see more research on
women um
and i think the last one is i'd like to
see more
uh more studies comparing high load and
low load training in uh in women
for a long time there there were
a dozen studies in men and there was a
2012 paper by schwinke
that was the only high load low load
study in women
since then i think there have been
either two or three more studies
um
that that have
found results that are similar to the
research on men
in that high load and low load training
seem to have
fairly similar effects on hypertrophy uh
the schwenke study though did find that
high load training was way way more
effective than low load training for
hypertrophy in women uh and there there
hasn't been like a major result like
that on the male side of things
uh so
i i would want to see
i think another probably two or three
high load low load
hypertrophy studies
in women
and actually there's one more i'd like
to see uh
more volume studies in women as well
like the impact of training volume on
hypertrophy and strength gains
most of most of that research
uses male subjects or predominantly male
subjects
and there's some reason to believe that
women
both maybe can tolerate higher levels of
training volume within a single session
like recovering better set to set
maybe recovering a little bit better
between resistance training sessions
than males do
so there's some reason to believe that
the optimal training volume for women
might be a little bit higher than the
optimal training volume for men
so i'd like to see
more volume studies on women
individually but then also
comparing the effects of various levels
of training volume
uh in both males and females within this
within the context of the same study to
see if
kind of that optimal level of volume um
seems to on average differ between sexes
i i suspect it does but there's there's
not enough research uh currently to say
for sure
good stuff
do you have any that you'd like to see
um
[Music]
nothing that really comes to mind like
i feel like
you already mentioned it but with the
supplement research there's just so much
that is
male heavy yeah um
and it has
it's changing you know um
there are a lot of studies coming out
that um
you know
pretty explicitly are just like yeah
we're testing this in in female
participants because we think we know
about the supplement and we've never
tried yeah um
yeah we think we know the effects of
this supplement but
when we look at the extant literature we
realize we only know the effects of this
supplement in about 49 of the population
yeah um
you know i i would be
just like an interesting aspect of
physiology i think is metabolic
flexibility
and given
differences in substrate utilization i
think it might be interesting to look at
how different nutritional patterns could
potentially influence
metabolic flexibility in males versus
females
i'm not sure it would be particularly
uh you know
actionable you know i don't think i
don't i'm not certain that there would
be a high degree of practical
application uh but i just think it's a
fascinating concept yeah um
diverge yeah i i think it'd be
interesting to look at um you know
more research on sex differences uh
in terms of different weight loss
strategies um different dietary
combinations and
um you know much like people have kind
of speculated that you know individuals
who are
more insulin resistant might do better
on this diet versus that diet i think
the more that we continue to explore
these kind of open research questions
the better but there's there's not like
one um
one particular topic where i'm like
that's that's what i'd like to see i got
you yeah oh uh this this wouldn't
necessarily be a males versus females
thing uh but one one other area where
i'd like to see more research in in
women in particular uh is looking at the
effects of uh menstrual cycle phase on
recovery from resistance training there
was a really cool paper by markowski in
2014 that looked at this uh finding that
recovery from
like a pretty brutal eccentric exercise
session uh was was considerably quicker
during the follicular phase of the cycle
versus the ludial phase
and i think that there's been
maybe one maybe two other papers since
then that have that have waded into
those waters but uh
man there's been a lot of there's been a
lot of research on
the impact of the menstrual cycle on
acute exercise performance across
basically every conceivable domain of
performance
you know aerobic capacity
repeated sprint performance
maximum dynamic strength maximum
isometric strength all types of stuff
looking at uh how different menstrual
cycle phases affect various things turns
out not all that much uh really but um
there hasn't been that much
looking at the effects of menstrual
cycle phases on recovery which
theoretically could have a notable
impact um
because uh sex hormones seem to
influence recovery from
muscle damage in in women quite a bit um
so estrogen tends to promote uh like
muscular healing and recovery uh post
training um you you can see that
uh
in women with different estrogen levels
you can see that when women go on
hormone replacement therapy um like if
they're post-menopausal um
and i mean just like kind of mechanistic
cell culture research shows that as well
there was a good a good review paper on
that i think from 2010 by ends and
colleagues en and s
um
but yeah so
theoretically with with fluctuating
estrogen levels uh throughout the
menstrual cycle
you could conceivably predict uh
different rates of of recovery from
resistance training and like i said that
markovsky study
suggests that it might have a have a
relatively large impact um
but yeah i want to see more follow-up
work in that area uh before stating that
with with a super high degree of
confidence that's that's another area
where where i definitely like to see
more research